We're looking at two different processes that counteract each other.
The growth of the fish and the harvesting of the fish. Let's ignore harvesting for the moment.
A simple assumption about the growth would be that the amount of fish increases year by year
by the same percentage similar to compound interest.
To make things simple, we are measuring the amount of fish
as a number of tons not by counting.
Here is a quiz for you. Let's not include harvesting.
What should the right of change of the amount of fish be: 0.5 per ton times the amount of fish
minus 4 * 10⁵ years per ton, or minus 0.5 per year times the amount of fish
plus 4 * 10⁵ tons per year, or plus 0.5 per year times the amount of fish
minus 4 * 10⁵ tons per year.